community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
all right here's a great story about a
wish come true for a young man thanks to
the good folks at finley automotive
group tyler quarter joins us today to
talk about how really a lot of people an
entire community came together to make a
wish come true for a young man who
wanted his car restored yeah so we've
been uh we've been working with
make-a-wish for a number of years and
granting wishes and and uh and it's it's
great because these people that when
they find out is that uh there's more
positive medical outcomes for people
that have a wish granted because they're
anticipating and their mental aspect is
good so so we love grant and wishes and
so recently they came to us with a young
man named gustavo who
is suffering from leukemia is 19 years
old and he had a 91 gmc pickup that he
wanted to have restored and fixed up and
so we took it over to our custom shop
and and did that and just a few weeks
ago we were able to present it to him
and you're so right about what these
wishes do the anticipation of the wish
is good not only for the young person
who is battling a life-threatening
illness but for the entire family as
well yeah absolutely it gives them
something positive to focus on and which
which is awesome and and you know what
they're finding right now is through the
pandemic there's an awful lot of wishes
that are on hold because so many wishes
are travel wishes and so they haven't
been able to grant uh those
a lot of them and they've been on hold
so now they're they're hoping that this
year they're going to double the amount
of wishes they were able to grant last
year because they're on a limited basis
starting to open up travel wishes and
you know that which is awesome a year
ago we did a wish for a four-year-old
elias that wanted to go to disneyland
and and he was suffering from leukemia
and to be able to grant that wish and
see the
kids
his his reaction to that so there's all
these wishes backed up and so a lot of
good stuff that they're hopefully going
to be able to clear that out so
beautiful so amazing oh here's some of
the the photos of the restored truck yes
that looks beautiful
gustavo yeah we he he kept it the same
color but we redid the the interior and
the paint job and uh the stereo system
and so forth fantastic yeah you know
what's fun about these wishes too
especially like the one for gustavo and
the one for the four-year-old who goes
to disneyland is that you do feel that
sense of community people love
chipping in and giving their time and
talent to make things like that happen
yeah you know we all want the very best
for these people these kids that are
fighting these critical illnesses and so
anything we can do to help them makes
makes us feel good obviously it's great
for the the person who's getting their
wish granted and their family but it
makes everyone that participates feel
good yes
you want the best for them absolutely
there truly is a power and a wish
granted that can't be found anywhere
else correct yeah yeah so we just love
support and make-a-wish we encourage
everybody to to check out what they do
and and we're going to continue to
support them we've done a number of
wishes over the years and hope to keep
doing doing that going forward you guys
have been so good to make a wish as well
as so many other non-profits and great
causes in the valley so thank you for
all of that it's all good it's all good
good to see you here in studio too it's
great i think it's been a long time
since we've actually sat face to face i
love being here in person oh amen all
right we want to thank finley automotive
group once again for sponsoring this
segment if you want more information you
can give make a wish of southern nevada
a call at that number
702-212-9474 it spells out wish if
you're old school
and you also can check them out online
wish.org
snb
mercedes